you
please be mindful of that
to make sure that what whatever you say
is uh well thought out and i would ask
you to be cautious
that when your microphone is on often it
will pick up
what you might be saying or whispering
to the person next to you
and i've been caught on that myself so
just be careful
turn your mic off
when you're not speaking
and please wait to be recognized to
speak
these are executive this is an executive
session all day
and it's liable to go quickly which is a
and
we're making some some hard decisions
rather than just listening
in the hearing mode we're going to make
some hard decisions
and
let's all understand that they're not
all going to be the way we want them to
go
so in some cases you have to swallow
okay
i'm going to open the executive session
today this is the municipal county
government committee and today is
february 22nd
we're going to start off
with house bill 1026
and we have about
10 bills to accept
and then we'll call it a day and then
we're going to do this all again
tomorrow we're going to have a full day
of exec
anybody needs to be excused for any
reason or go to the bathroom or whatever
let me know and
uh
the ranking member and i may have a
discussion about how we
may want to take a recess or not to give
you time to go and come back
no we're we're not
planning to wait for someone to leave
to take a quick vote and get and gain
the advantage uh that's not that's not
uh in today's plan so just ruin my whole
strategy yes right
right
okay uh house bill 1026 this was the uh
this is relative to having the proper
budget information
uh on a spreadsheet provided to the
budget committee
is there a motion
for this bill
not to pass
motion is made out to pass is there a
second
okay motion motion's been made out to
pass on 10 26
and it's been seconded is there any
seeing no discussion mr chair just one
more question yes go ahead the bill is
all right seeing no further discussion
uh that's the
clerk to take a
roll
okay hb 1026 ought to pass uh vice
chairman pm monty
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
representative rhodes
representative melvin
representative
representative power yes
representative trey levin
yes
representative gilman
representative majori yes
uh representative mega pooty
yes yes okay
representative vann
representative klee
yes
representative
gallagher yes
representative run yes
okay
yes uh without objection i'll i'll be
moving that to the consent calendar
and uh
representative piermont you're going to
do the
report
the next bill
is
house bill 1055
which has to do with property tax
exemptions
for individuals with disabilities and
those who are deaf or surveilling
all right let's take the amendment first
so uh
is your motion to uh
okay
so this first vote here on 1055 is on
the amendment only
like we said was uh
2022-0139
h is in hotel
any discussion
on that amendment mr chair yes a
question about the procedural we are
just taking up the amendment without the
bill as otp
first
i'm confused with the procedure but
representative could you turn off your
it's been a while since uh you've had to
live up to that
yes ma'am
you mr chair i just have a question
about the amendment
it starts with number four on line nine
and i'm looking for that on the bill
and i see that number four is the
effective date so is this is this number
four to replace that and
just not quite sure where this amendment
that's a good question does anybody have
any thoughts on that rich
representative lasallus
yes just above that if you look above it
it says amend a bill by inserting after
section 3
the following and renumbering the
original section 4 to read his 5. got it
thank you mr chair
one of the concerns that we had had was
the one year
residency has that not changed
uh
i believe it's been it has been changed
from five years to one year
okay
yes representative gallagher
i'm not seeing the changing it from five
or
um
yeah the part about it changing
from five years to one year that was in
the original bill correct and then the
amendment doesn't do anything to address
that so it would just
stay as being reduced from five years to
one year
thank you mr chair um my recollection
was there are three bills that are all
tax credit ones yes and my
notes says is there a way to
uh
connect or combine that three
and also for fiscal note on three for
the impact
so any
update on that
no the right now the way we've set them
up is we're gonna have to take each
individually
and i believe they're all ch they're all
have are going to be proposed to be
changed from a a longer time period to a
shorter time period all the same
and
in our discussion we can
certainly uh advocate one versus the
other you know staying at five going to
one year whatever how how you feel
about that but we're not they're not
linked together
and uh further yes clarification how
about the fiscal note for
this the impact
i want to ask the clerk to make a note
of that i i believe
that's not required but we'll make a
yes
thank you uh when we first considered
this um
i think part of our discussion was the
fact that many municipalities or
municipalities have the
flexibility
uh at this point uh that they can do
essentially what this bill is asking for
and i think a large part of our
objection was that residential or that
the residency requirement
uh which i do think we'll have
discussions and other amendments that we
have coming up here which changed it to
three
um i still think that i am i i see some
improvement with this amendment but the
fact that it doesn't change the
residency requirement or changes it to
one
uh gives me cause to to vote against
this given that in part of the testimony
we heard
that the uh sponsor of the bill thought
even three was arbitrary so if three was
arbitrary but is the standard then one
seems even more arbitrary because
there's no basis
so i'm inclined to vote against the
amendment um given that municipalities
will still have the right to do
what this bill
is trying to allow them to do thank you
any other comment about go ahead
uh
i believe this is uh not a tax credit
this is a tax exemption so the the
large as uh
a tax credit would be so good
any other comments on 1055 yes
representative plea
um thank you mr chair
my only concern is that
while this is just a tax credit every
dollar that we save from any single
group
gets passed on to other groups
and my concern is that knowing all these
bills that are coming forward we're
heading down a slippery slope i can tell
you that i am
i was on a committee last session
not last year
as the chair of
state fed
relations and and veterans affairs and
we had a veterans bill
that was similar to um that particular
was a credit i agree but we've been
doing year after year we continue to do
these things and my concern is that we
really are passing the burden on to
someone else whether it be by
reducing their tax liability
through a credit or through reducing
their assessed value
um
we keep saying we want to get more and
more young people into our
state
and we're doing everything we can to
stop that by happening by adding to
their real estate burden so
for that reason i
while i feel guilty saying no to this i
think i'm going to have to uh
pass thank you representative manjuputi
thank you mr chair you know having
worked with
this population for over 30 years as a
therapist and seeing how
their lives are impacted
one year residency
is too short for somebody
in this predicament where you know
they're trying to figure out where they
get the services where they can settle
down
and
if they have to keep moving from one
community to the other and also
it's a lot of effort
so one year just giving one year
residency requirement that gives them a
false hope of being able to apply for
something and by the time they're able
to get that it may not be the community
that they want to uh be in so
you know it takes a little more and i am
all for supporting
this
but i think the time frame and the way
it's worded
is not really beneficial to this
group very group we are trying to help
and with that i will vote against this
okay
just as a reminder we are voting on the
amendment
for hb 1055 which is an exemption for
the blind
thank you mr chair and i apologize this
may not be germane to the amendment but
i just noticed something that i didn't
notice before
which makes me question
some technical aspects of how this bill
might be
or might not be enforced which is the
communities typically only
therefore
somebody who's lived in a property for
one year or even three years
it would be difficult if not impossible
and it might cause a tremendous amount
of work for assessors
in towns and cities to go back and
figure out well what is the true value
of this residence
right the the uh as i understand it the
towns are required
required to
reevaluate every minimum every five
years but they can do it more frequently
if asked to or if they see market forces
or someone puts in a request for an
abatement
i realize that i just pointed out as a
could be a a source of a problem for the
bill and and and because of those
technical problems and because of the
downshifting of property taxes
that some people may not have to pay
should this bill passes those will get
downshifted to other people in the
community i i will need to vote against
this thank you for the input thanks uh
any other further compliment uh rather
input on the amendment we are voting on
okay the amendment to
house bill 1055
basically changes it from a
five-year
exemption to a one-year exemption
all right i'll ask the clerk to take a
roll
uh vice chairman p monty yes clerk votes
yes representative tripp i vote yes
representative guthrie yeah
los alas
yes representative rhodes
yes representative melvin yeah
representative
yes
representative power yes
uh representative trailer
uh representative gilman no
representative majori no
representative stavis no
representative mega pooty
no
representative vann
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
representative run no
chairman dolan yes
the member passes 10 to 9.
yeah i would ask that
representative
i'm sorry
details detail okay so the amendment
passed ten to nine so now
the original bill 1055
as amended
uh do i have any further discussion on
that
well i agree that uh the intent of this
is very good it's time to raise the
exemption for
people in need um i do have a problem
with the one-year
am also concerned about the downshift of
the cost to people the very people that
we're trying to attract to the state
thank you any further discussion on the
on the on the bill representative
mcdonald
representative
thank you mr chair um
for the same reasons that my colleague
to my right
mentioned and also having worked with
this group
i know this is a very well intended but
it's going to create a lot more
confusion and
uh mis
wrong expectation
of
people who are moving in families with
uh individuals with disability who are
moving into the state
will have
with uh you know discrepancy between one
year five-year assessment and tax credit
or tax
um
exemption so i think there'll be more
confusion more
issue with the process so with that i
would
vote against it
and hope that next term will have a
better
well thought out bill
seen seen no further comments uh last
representative heir if you want to make
and is there a
second i'll second that
okay
uh otp has amended on house bill 1055.
now right seven pminty yes click votes
yes representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative rhodes
yes
melvin yes
representative yes
representative power yes
representative trail oven no
representative gilman no
representative mijori no
representative davis no
representative mega puti
no
representative
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
ought to pass those amended passes uh 10
to
9. thank you miss uh mr clerk and i
would ask
representative ayer if you write the
the next bill we're gonna look at is uh
house bill 1056
mr chair
yes just asking there won't be any
minority report on this because it's ten
thank you we'll decide that mr chair um
hopefully we'll get back to you tomorrow
with everybody who's doing minority
reports or reports from the democrat
okay so back to 1056
this is
a bill relative to veterans tax credits
uh representative mcdonald do you have a
motion to make on this
yes i'll make a motion of uh to pass
mr chair quick question sorry is there's
an amendment to
isn't there an amendment to 1055
not 1056. uh if there is i don't have
one
so 0498 was to 10.55
yes
zero one three nine eight
so zero four nine eight which says it
was to ten fifty five is not in that
applicable here that was another
amendment that went with
ten fifty five okay
okay so we're back to uh representative
mcdonald just made a motion to
otp for
bill
president lasallus makes a second
yes representative please thank you
mr chair
once again i
putting the minimums and the maximums
the issue here is those
um towns or cities that have the um
50 minimum
now will have to push it up to 200 and
it's going to have an effect on them
personally the town that i come from
this will not have an effect on
but we're also pushing the 750 up to 900
which does put pressure from
municipalities to municipalities
and once again i just feel that we're
just
passing the burden on
and i'm and i'm quite concerned
who is going to be taking this in the
end so thank you
representative manjuputi
thank you mr chair
i you know my concern
adding to representative please is um
smaller communities are going to share
the burden
and
larger cities uh like ours
that i come from
already provides a lot of
support
and uh
but it will affect the high end
um
where it goes from 750 to 900
and
you know with that
i will have a harder time
uh supporting it and i do understand
this will have
you know if the current thing exists and
more uh female veterans
are able to enroll in the existing
current one
and this then there's an even
distribution of uh veterans across the
state with all the communities share it
it would be
helpful so um
with that
i would uh not be able to support it
i'd like to point out that this is an
enabling bill
and
the towns that are
interested in providing the tax credit
can do so if they want
i do agree that
the minimum is being increased from
fifty dollars to two hundred dollars but
uh as was presented during the testimony
uh the fifty dollars is from the civil
war
i think it might be time to increase the
the minimum to uh something that's a
little more uh 2000-ish so uh
with that in mind i
will
support this bill thank you very much
thank you mr chair um i'm gonna
i think we'll be hearing this a few
times but
i agree that something from the civil
war should probably be updated but with
that should have the fiscal analysis
that shows us what the impact is going
to be
with all due respect this bill should
have had a fiscal note to it
we understand the process that that
would have to go through but when we
have to think about the impact that this
will have or could have
those of us familiar with municipal
budgeting we always have to budget for
worst case scenario and i don't consider
this worst case but you have to consider
what will the impact be
statewide since we're thinking about
this and and we could have done that you
know that homework is possible to do for
dra which is why if we can do it i think
this should have had a fiscal note to it
so if somebody asked me what's the
impact i could say i don't know
and i and i can't go back to people and
say i don't know when i know the
information was available so i have to
um another question mr chair you know we
all heard the governor's state of the
state and uh if there's a huge
veterans campus being
raised in
franklin 100 million dollars
and uh this would be a good opportunity
for
town of franklin to look at how it's
going to impact or how it benefits and
you know seems like that would be a
great opportunity to look at how that
pans out before we make a statewide
change
i hate to repeat myself but once again
this is an enabling bill
i i think since it is an enabling bill
and it can be uh
enabled at different values since uh the
the uh
value is changing from 750 to 900
uh
it it's there's going to be variation uh
since it is once again an enabling bill
not every town will
adopt it it's an interesting thought
that you could uh
produce a fiscal note for this but
there's a number of unknown variables
here which would make it very difficult
difficult for it to be anywhere accurate
thank you
yeah let me add in that i know in my
the way that the
governing body is implementing these
things is
as they look at the
financial ability to absorb this cost
they're
taking these
these uh
tax credits up by 50 a year
to kind of phase it in as opposed to uh
take it all at once
yes representative i think
thank you
representative clee and mr chair
um my understanding from the clerk
is that if
a committee wishes to see a fiscal note
that is a matter that can be voted upon
at the executive session
you're very that's very true
therefore what i'm proposing for your
consideration since we have a raft of
bills
to exec today that deal with the
specific issue of tax exemptions and tax
credits
that we consider taking a vote on
whether these particular bills require
fiscal notes in order for us to
responsibly
cast a vote in support or not of them
okay
correct me if i'm wrong but this
is enabling legislation that would have
to be passed by a town
through in the case of in my case a
warrant article
so the impact the fiscal impact on the
state
would would not
there would be no fiscal impact on the
state it would be on the individual town
correct
uh thank you mr chair was there someone
in front of me
okay thank you um
two things this this is
is in fact enabling legislation however
those that already have it
must abide by this or they're going to
have to repeal
this
these credits they would actually have
to take them away
or they're going to have to abide by
going from 50
dollars to 200
there's also another
um added thing in here that
um the the term not less than 90 days
on active service has been struck
i don't think that would
truly take a whole lot of individuals
that would fall into that category but
that also does add to the the numbers
that would um
would qualify for the uh for the credit
but as as enabling
we we talk about that the community has
to vote in order to have it however if
they've already have it
then they have to go from
they have no choice in it they have to
go from the 50 to the 200.
um so
their choice is going to be we stop it
as far as a fiscal note is it would be a
fiscal note local so it would be an fnl
not a just a regular fiscal note
because it does affect
the truth is it doesn't affect the
municipalities per se but it affects the
taxpayers within the municipality as
they have to pick up the burden
so for instance the city of nashua or
the town of merrimack and so on they're
not going to be their budgets aren't
going to be affected but their residents
will be affected by this so thank you
representative power
thank you mr chair um representative
klee made the point to that that i was
raising my hand to make and that is
while this is in fact enabling
legislation there are municipalities
who have which have already adopted this
so if this were to pass then this would
be um
they would have to abide by it
by the the
the fiscal
changes
okay
stavis do you want to
have another whack at this
um could i make a motion microphone
um
well would it be an order to make a
motion to request a fiscal note
um
i think we need to uh
dis
disposition the motion we have and then
mr chair
yes um would it be in order for the this
current
motion on the table be withdrawn then
the other motion can be made any motion
can be withdrawn okay
mr chair yes i mean if we do vote on the
motion
on the tape table on the bill in other
words
then
the need for a fiscal note would be moot
because we wouldn't have the information
i understand
what i'm going to allow is that if the
motion
passes then i'm going to open the floor
up to see if anybody wants to make a
motion to add a fiscal note to any of
these bills
and
the committee
that has the
power to do that
okay so
where we are yes where is representative
thank you mr chair um
my challenge is that my vote on on this
bill would be dependent on the fiscal
note if there is a a
large
in my opinion a large
tax
hit that property tax owners in towns
would have to take for this that would
influence my vote
so it's difficult to to vote otp without
having an understanding of the tax
implications for the communities that
already have this credit i understand
but we're in the voting mode now so it's
trip
um
i was going to say that there
would be
no
tax implication but
because it's primarily a tax shift
it being a tax credit but uh
i'm going to have to withdraw that
statement because the the increase from
50 to two hundred dollars is a definite
uh tax impact so uh
i'm corrected thank you
thanks
mr chair yes
and i'm looking on the thank you mr
chair i'm looking you know as we did
before on dra there's a 33-page report
that that has all of the towns listed
with what they already have
this information is not hard to get i
would not want to be the one to be
responsible for saying this is the
impact it just seems that dra
and i don't know who makes those
decisions when the bills are are first
assigned but that's the information that
we that we are hoping to get from this
um may be negligible maybe you know
maybe completely negligible but there
will be a shall in this
i just we
hoping for as we've heard before full
disclosure so that we can be confident
in our decision so without the fiscal
note i'm going to vote against it's not
because i want to vote against the
veterans in any way shape or form but i
need to know that i've done my due
diligence thank you thank you i am
confident that because it's an enabling
piece of legislation
the dra's position is going to be that
there is no fiscal impact
because the town is going to have to
choose
to implement or not and if they choose
not to implement the zero
impact and it will be very difficult the
dra to calculate the financial impact if
it's going to be as variable as
the warren article that appears in each
community
thank you chairman except for the fact
that towns which already have this tax
exemption
will be required to go to the larger sum
so while it is enabling it is also
compelling for towns that already have
the exemption
representatives davis
yeah i would just like to go back to um
the time when we
heard these bills
and i made a
special mention of the fact that none of
them had fiscal notes and i believe
the clerk made a note or said he would
make a note of that
and so i would again put forward a
motion that before we
make a decision
that has significant or maybe not
significant we just don't know
fiscal impact on the state and or its
taxpayers
that we have the information at hand to
help us make that decision
i i hear what you're saying but that
motion is not in order at this time
yes representative majipudi uh thank you
mr chair um
i have in my notes from that public
hearing
48 communities out of 250 yard
communities are providing less than 200
dollar tax credit 17 communities offer
750 tax credit
just the two ex
ends of the bookends and this is from
the assassin of
hudson so this at least looking at this
is 65 communities are going to be
impacted
uh you know and it's
what percentage of it at least 20
of the communities are
little more than at 25 of the
communities so knowing that these many
communities are going to be impacted
i you know
doing our due diligence i think having a
fiscal
note would help
me to make that decision saying that
i've done everything i can
understanding and voted on it and i
think we need to do our due diligence
from that i would request that that mr
clerk could you just remind us
the status we are in the discussion this
bill we had an
are we at otp of 1056 or are we still on
there's no amendment right
okay any further discussion
is the most motion to retain it uh in
order now
we don't
we don't have the motion to retain would
okay uh mr clerk would you call the
okay the motion is otp on house bill
1056.
uh vice chairman pm monty yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp i
vote yes representative guthrie
representative losalis
yes
representative rhodes
representative melvin
yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative eleven no
representative gilman no
representative majorie no
representatives davis no
representative mega poody no
representative
representative klee no
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong no
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 10 to 9.
okay
representative
mcdonald are you going to
write the committee report yes
all right at this point i'm going to
entertain a motion
regarding
having the finance committee
review
i will make that motion mr chairman
okay
and
uh is there a second
um so just to clarify
um you said for any number of these
bills which of them specifically are we
requesting
fiscal notes for we're going to go back
to representative lasallus to see
when he's made his motion which what
does he want it to apply to
i i would think mr chairman that we
should take them up
for
this particular
bill
to have a fiscal note on it
and then at the completion of each bill
to say whether we want a fiscal load or
not all right so so the motion as
clarified is uh on
the motion is to add a fiscal note
to alert the finance committee to review
this
for financial impact of the communities
yes representative maturi thank you mr
chair i appreciate i certainly
appreciate that that's the direction uh
that we want to go clearly we've heard
that i just i'm unclear on process
getting a fiscal note versus sending
this to a second committee for all
intent and purpose
um i'm not saying i'm against what we
want to do i just want to make sure
we're doing it the right way i and i
have no idea
so because this couldn't be a second
committee bill could it
okay
and to get that clarity too because we
might have the same question i think
we're going to have the same question on
a couple of other bills so whatever the
process is i think i think you might
have some support
why don't i do this why don't i take a
short recess and we'll get some clarity
on the process how's that sound right
okay we're going to be in uh
uh
we had a motion
on uh 1056 and that motion passed right
yes okay so so we're at the point where
uh just on the calendar here we're at
the point where we was going to start
hb 1057 shortly
but in the meantime we're going to get
some process direction and so let's take
you know if it hasn't come through with
one already
too late gotta vote for it at the
executive session which is why i made my
motion right
um
i don't think sending it to another
committee
is the way it's done i think it's we the
buck stops with us
you know we have the fiscal note or we
vote to request a fiscal note and then
we vote again on the bill based on the
information we have but i think
sending it to another so your thought is
paul's direction is that we would vote
in a fiscal note yeah while it's here
and then we revoke to decide whether we
want to
ipl or otp to go with the physical note
yes it's up to us okay
that's easier that's easier than what i
was going to do yeah so that's i'm going
to call him and people are going to tell
me the same thing you want me to show
yes
we've had that discussion and we're all
in that in that direction okay thank you
i just wanted to make sure we are on the
okay
oh
that
yeah
zero
is
i i think the amendment should be
passed
because the commission
um
okay
[Music]
would you agree with that
yes
just a side note yeah that's how much
tax burden
that we shift to anybody who doesn't
fall into any of those other ones
hundred and twenty 55
thousand dollars
then we're shifting to all the young
people
i'm gonna do uh i'm gonna entertain
the taxpayers so if you don't fall into
this category if you're twenty-something
moving it around
the clerk needs to get some more
paperwork
and uh this one 1057.
that's a tax exemption for the elderly
and this one was the tax exemption for
the disabled so it was three they were
implement to make everybody feel
comfortable
is on these three bills
i'll look for a motion to reconsider the
bills okay okay and that will put it
back on the table and then we can revoke
that's awesome and
so but
i'm concerned about the fact we're going
to lose a lot of time so they're going
to get you to try to help more i'll do
it
is
hello
um
i forgot let me look
around yeah because i forgot absolutely
it's the default budget
bill
okay this is municipal county government
in executive session
here on 2 22 22
and we where we left off we took a
recess was
on house bill 1057 getting ready to go
to house bill 1069
but what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna we're gonna uh
have a little stutter step here
and i'm gonna look to see do i have a
motion
to reconsider
yes we have a motion from representative
davis is there a second and second
representative
okay this is the bill relative the tax
exemption
for those with disabilities and severely
hearing impaired
yes thank you mr chair i'd be happy to
um i i
put forward this
second and just motion or put forward
this motion
so that the committee could get the
fiscal notes that it needs to make a
responsible and well-informed decision
on all of these bills that propose tax
exemptions or tax credits
because all of them in some way shape or
form
have a downshifting effect on other
taxpayers in our communities and we
simply need to know
how much of an effect that might be
in order to make
a sound well-informed vote on these
bills because we're going to take them
one at a time
thank you
okay there's been a motion
to reconsider
house bill 1055 is there a second do we
have a second diamond representative
banjo puti seconds the motion
uh
i could ask the clerk to call a roll on
reconsideration
okay the motion is to reconsider house
bill 1055.
uh vice chairman pm monty yes
click votes yes
representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative silas
yes
representative rhodes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative yes
representative gilman yes
representative majority
yes representatives davis yes
representative
yes
representative klee yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes are 19-0 okay now that we
have on the table of 10 55 to be
reconsidered can i ask
representatives davis to
elaborate you did it already but if you
could do it for the record this time
what you want reconsidered and how you
want it to be reconsidered
thank you mr chair
um
i would like to reconsider 1055
in order to give this committee time to
obtain a fiscal note which will give us
precise information or even ballpark
information on what kind of an impact
passing or not passing this bill might
have either on the state or on the
residents of the towns and
are forced or choose to adopt this
increase in tax exemptions and credits
thank you so just to clarify uh as i
hear you're you're asking the committee
to reconsider
house bill 1055 as amended
no
not necessarily i think we have to wait
until we get that information
from
the fiscal we won't be waiting for
any of the fiscal notes what they what
happens in the process is the request
for fiscal notes goes to the speaker's
office and then they make a decision
whether to
get a fiscal note or not
that's different from what the clerk
told me
but
mr speaker
thank you mr chairman i think we've
already voted to reconsider that's the
vote that we just took right so now
we're obligated to vote again on 10 55
right the question is do we want to
bring another motion before
we consider the vote on 10 55 so we've
already agreed that we're going to talk
it over again
um
so that's right your recommendation is
to
my recommendation
no my recommendation is not otp my
recommendation is that we
uh request
um
more information about the shifting my
understanding is it's what about 55
yes 55 million 627 000
is going to be shifted from one citizen
group to another citizen group if all of
these bills that deal with exemptions
right my thought was that the motion
so procedural is that possible you
explained to us that otpa when we were
voting for woody pa the reason we voted
against that was because we didn't have
the fiscal note and you're safe
yeah no we are reconsidering but you're
saying we won't get it back so without
getting the fiscal note asking us to
vote for otpa
doesn't make any sense in my mind maybe
i'm kind of tunnel vision but just
explain to me
the other motion now that we have
reconsidered in a unanimous
reconsideration
would it be
possible to have
um other motion now for example like
itl and when it gets to the floor if we
have the
fiscal note float amendment and then
overturn it
our request there a fiscal note
is a is a request
and that we're not going to get any
full with the full assembly
that it doesn't bounce back to us for us
to make a decision whether we agree or
not with the physical node or what what
the fiscal note makes us think of
that ours is an open recommendation to
the to the speaker
that this requires a fiscal note and he
can decide whether it does or not yeah
follow-up mr chair so it makes sense to
say you know pending fiscal note
we voted itl so if the fiscal note comes
in as a floor amendment
at the session then we have the full
yes representative matt jory
mr chairman i'm curious um if we have to
no we do not
could it
my follow-up then to that is so in order
to avoid the possibility or the the
potential of confu of additional
confusing about voting on on the
disposition of this bill
can we send that request
to the speaker's office if it is
approved we'll get the fiscal note if
it's denied we won't and then we can
dispose of the bill pending that
decision
at one of our other
we can we can try and see what they see
if they get back to us this is
unprecedented in my
me too and my uh tour here so i i'm not
uh
i'm not telling you what's going to
happen
representatives davis i feel a little
bit back to the future here because i
think that was indeed my original motion
um
and and if i may mr chair just say a few
words about
this group of bills
i think that it is the responsible thing
for
this committee out of all committees to
do
to very carefully weigh and measure the
potential impact
that the many many bills that come
before us requesting tax exemptions or
tax credits for special groups of people
over other groups of people
if it doesn't get considered here as a
matter of public policy for this state
it will not be considered anywhere and i
think we have a solemn obligation
to fully understand
the impact of shifting these dollars
from one group to another
when any bill comes before us that
requests an increase in existing tax
exemption or a new tax credit
and i thank you for letting me speak
okay thank you uh
mr chairman i see your hand up let me
suggest this that
rather than prolong this discussion
i'm going to suggest that
the motions we have on the floor be
withdrawn
and that
you
designate me to
go forward with the
recommendation that the committee wants
to see fiscal notes on these three bills
and
what what that means and we'll get some
output out of the speaker's office and
i'll bring it back to you tomorrow thank
you so much
yes yes mr chairman i just want to make
a point of order we had a vote to
reconsider
the motion otpa
so we can suspend uh someone can
withdraw
that motion the the otpa motion but
that's the the only course of action we
can do now in in my opinion you can
please correct me if i'm wrong is
to re-vote on otpa
as we are allowed under the the approved
motion to reconsider or suspend
but if we come back or whoever made the
motion can withdraw it and the second
can be withdrawn but when we do
reconvene on this bill
our our order of business would be to
vote on re take a re-vote on otpa we
can't entertain another motion because
the only thing we're allowed to
reconsider is otpa
right but we can withdraw the motion
typically we only have four
four actions that we can take one is otp
one is itl
one is otpa
and the fourth one is interim study
those are our four options
so we're kind of
skirting around this a little bit and
just delaying it to try to get to
whether we want otp or itl this
so that's where we are uh yes
representative manchputi uh with the
reconsideration we can vote it up or
down right if we can the reconsideration
the motion is still on the table yeah so
we could say no so we are not
reconsidering and the otpa stays
on it what i'm suggesting is that
those who made the motion withdraw their
motion and it will start fresh tomorrow
with input that i get from the
speakers yes representative
we voted to reconsider
so now we're back at otpa
so i think that our choice is either
to vote again on otpa vote it down
get the fiscal notes
and
or could we table it i mean could we
table it and pick it up tomorrow the
tabling's not in order the tabling's not
in order
um because we have already voted to
i don't think so we we voted can we
recon can we withdraw a motion that
we've voted on we didn't vote yeah yeah
we did they
yeah we voted to reconsider we called
i don't know uh thank you mr chair i
know everybody's head is ready to
explode so
um
the the
what you've agreed to take on is to to
go forward and to find out what the uh
fiscal note is on it
i
if i'm not being out of line could i ask
that we
that we ask what the
fiscal impact of this is on the
taxpayers
as was stated all of our
credits
um this the dra puts it on as taxes lost
when it's really not its taxes burden
shift
and 2020 was 55 million 627
496. so if we could get more of what the
impact is as if it's going to i don't
think we can but
it's on the dra report that's right so
if we had it formally for all of the
members rather than us each having to
look it up it would be wonderful thank
you okay representative van is correct
that we have voted to reconsider this
bill so i'm going to suggest that we
vote that down
and give and if you
you
get the chairman
wherever he might be to go find out
find out about the fiscal notes
so we're not in an in-between with some
fiscal notes and
some reconsideration i'm going to
suggest that we
we vote reconsideration down
and then we start fresh tomorrow with
mr chair i move to continue house bill
whichever one we're on
10 55
to
uh i think i need a motion to continue
needs to be to a date certain
yes so at the risk of not having all the
information i would move to
continue
this bill
until february 28th and keep my fingers
and toes crossed that we have something
with the risk that if we don't have it
why can't we move to continue yes yes
ma'am
if i may make a friendly suggestion
we
we did certainly already vote
the the reconsider
perhaps we could just put this aside for
a minute call the house clerk and ask
him to come over
and
explain exactly where we are in the
process and what exactly we need to do
to be able to move forward i don't think
that that would be out of line to just
put it
aside for a few minutes while he walks
over
from the tunnel and then we could move
on to other business while he's on his
okay thank you
mr chair i'd be happy to make that
request of him
i think that's my responsibility uh
i kind of got us where we are now and
maggiore i appreciate your your idea
but i'm determined that uh we either
take up this bill
executive today or tomorrow
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna take that
up during our lunch break we're gonna
tackle a few more bills while we still
have some time here
all right are you all confused as much
um
we'll take a recess and after a couple
more bills and i'll give myself and
representatives davis if she wants to
accompany me
to search out some answers here
we're kind of in uncharted territory
we'll learn what the right road is here
all right the next uh
is house bill 1069 which is relative to
the election of the village district
representative tripp do you have a
motion
i move uh
otp
uh house bill 10 57 10 10 60 oh 10 69
sorry yes uh
is there a second
second
okay representative
seconds it
is a discussion on hb 1069.
i did pass out an amendment mr chair to
we all should you all have that
amendment
would you like to present what the
amendment changes
right
yes at the um
public hearing there was a question
whether
um we should just
strike
um
just not just have it for any any
village district that wants to go from
three to five
because the
um
the current rsa
only limits that increase to the towns
of merrimack and hooksett
but there
there was an interest in increasing this
in another town
so my amendment
would um
allow any village district in the state
if they want to go from three to five
they can do so at their annual meeting
and then those additional
commissioners that would be added if the
town if the village district agreed to
do that
representative power
thank you mr chair um
i'm a little bit lost here so i just
need some clarification i have in my
possession two amendments
to this bill are we which
which amendment
okay
thank you
i don't have another amendment if there
is a second amendment so so the
the basic
uh change here with the amendment
changes it from
just merrimack and hooksett application
to
any village or any town
correct mr chair the original bill
added with
districts within belknap county
and the towns of merrimack and hooksett
merrimack and hooksett are already in
rsa
but the bill originally was to allow
only districts within belknap county
during the public hearing i raised the
issue whether
we should not allow any whether we
should allow any
all village districts to make that
decision to go from three to five if
they so wish and so that was the basis
for my amendment okay representative
tripp do you have a motion on this
amendment
i move otp on uh
483 h
any discussion
1069 amendment zero four eight three
h
uh vice chairman pmit yes
collect votes yes representative tripp
tripp vote cs representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative rhodes yes
representative melvin yes
representative
okay
um
representative triloban yes
representative gilman
yes
representative mijori
representatives davis yes
representative megapuri yes
representative vann
representative klee yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan
and chairman dolan yes uh motion passes
19-0 so representative tripp do you have
a motion uh with
house bill 1069 as amended
i move o-t-p-a on house bill
is there a second
i second that mr chair okay thank you
any further discussion
would you take the role
mr
clerk on
otp as amended
clerk votes yes representative tripp i
vote yes representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative rhodes yes representative
melvin yes representative
uh representative power yes
representative tray levin yes
representative gilman yes
representative majority yes
representatives davis yes
representative megaputi yes
representative vann
representative clee yes representative
gallagher
yes
representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 19-0
with uh without objection i'll put that
okay next up
thank you
mr chair yes
we have the clerk here
oh
welcome uh well why don't i take a uh
a five minute recess and we'll get some
input from our
our
clerk
on where we were with the uh with the
fiscal note request
come join us paul with a little
conversation
we have three
pieces of legislation in front of us at
least three
where the committee is feeling like it
uh that there's enough fiscal impact
in their opinion that they like to
request fiscal notes for those three
bills
and so we were kind of stuck on what the
process would be
thank you mr chairman uh good morning
members of the committee
so the situation is that
you can ask for a fiscal note um you
have to be in executive session and you
actually have to take a vote as a
committee to request of the legislative
budget assistance office a request for a
fiscal note i would note however we are
now past the deadline for early bills
so even if you do ask for a fiscal note
at this point
in order to be assigned to a second
committee you will need to suspend any
house rules for action
so just be mindful of that
um that second committee has to suspend
the rules no the full house would have
to do that
if if
if a fiscal note is returned stating
that you uh
if it if it comes back showing it's
going to appropriate three million
dollars or something like that um then
uh in order to go to a second committee
which it would need to uh would require
a rule suspension to do that
well
the clerk is here we have questions for
him yes
thank you chairman
thank you
mr clerk
the question that we have is that we
have a set of bills which change the tax
exemptions for various classes of
persons
looking at the dras information it looks
to us as though this is going to
transfer the burden
in excess of 50 million dollars if they
all were to pass as now proposed
transfer something in the neighborhood
of 50 million dollars from one class of
persons to another class of persons we'd
like to know that it it doesn't affect
the state's budget
but it does affect individual taxpayers
and by extension
the towns and cities
so our question is how can we get that
information so that we can make an
informed decision and do i understand
that what you're saying is that at this
juncture we can no longer get that
information not at all um you could take
a vote as a committee to request a
fiscal note i would note however when
these bills are reviewed and every bill
is reviewed by the speaker when they're
assigned um every bill
is determined at that point whether or
not it needs to go to a second committee
and historically based on
based on the text that's in front of you
now
most of these bills these property tax
bills specifically
don't historically go to a second
committee which is why
they might not have been assigned us
previously
thank you mr chair no i understand why
it wouldn't go to a second committee
what we're trying to figure out is what
are we doing to the citizens sure by all
means as i mentioned the
getting a request for a fiscal note um
is is within your purview to do
mr chair
yes representative
i i have a procedural question we took a
vote on a bill
ought to pass as amended yes and
it
10 to 9
and
then the reconsideration
of that bill
passed unanimously so now we are sitting
at reconsideration
when we are looking at reconsideration
we either have to vote it down or
reinstate
otpa isn't that correct
uh no no so if you voted to reconsider
you are now at the last motion that was
acted on which is otpa
um that being said if this is one of
those bills that you're looking for that
information on um
the the chair can recess the executive
session on that particular
piece of legislation while you're
awaiting that
the result of the fiscal note
follow-up just a quick follow-up message
yeah so that means the reconsideration
can hold and that will stay as on the
table as we reconsider
because of the situation you're in
you can
the recess
when you come back the motion is still
pending of ought to pass as amended
okay thank you representative gallagher
so
for the chair to
recess the executive session
while we wait for
a fiscal note do we have to motion for
the chair to do that or is it just
entirely up to his own prerogative
thank you mr chairman thank you mr clerk
i have a question about fiscal notes
is
is there a difference between us asking
dra for some information some
you know about the the tax implications
for this other class of persons
um is there a difference between that
and a formal fiscal note on a bill
where
there's a report from dra that list what
fiscal impacts would be
yes
the if you request a fiscal note that
and
the processes the legislative budget
assistance office
would then contact whichever agency
would be responsible for compiling that
information the agency would then
respond with whatever
whatever their estimates would be and
that would actually be physically
attached to the legislation
whereas if you requested
directly from dra right now and sent an
email
and just said we're looking for this
information it would not be attached to
the actual piece of legislation however
you could certainly submit it such that
it it goes
um into the record for the the committee
okay thank you so there's really two
types like there's information financial
information we're getting on a tax
impact and then there's a formal fiscal
note
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
clark
so if
following up on representative rung's
question
in the latter case when we're if we were
just to ask for information from dra
would we still then have to suspend
house rules
if if
if if the information that you receive
uh
states that that they think that this is
going to require some sort of additional
tax
or appropriation
or a penalty or something along the
lines that would necessitate it to go to
a second committee
then
but that's somewhat different than just
a reapportionment of taxes amongst
citizens that's correct right
so so in that in that case if that's the
specific information we seek
not you know how how much is this going
to make taxes go up
but
how much
tax is going to be shifted from one
class of people to another class that
should not affect uh that should not
affect the problem a second committee
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
clerk
um no ball tied today
um the
the question i have kind of just for
clarification
in this case where there is no
burden to the the city the state the
town village district of any sort
going to the lba for a fiscal note
they're just going to come back with
zero because this is this affects the
individual
taxpayers
and not that is
would you say that that to be correct i
could not say that because
even even if you um if you requested
a fiscal note they would likely do a
deep dive and try to come back with
something for you um
the at the end of the day
fiscal notes
are not always about appropriations
they're not always about tax and fee
increases but there are significant
costs associated with various aspects of
government and
this committee actually gets several of
these fiscal notes every year where
where the fiscal note will state uh this
does transfer one you know
one tax base to another um
but
i i would tend to think that lba
would have suggested that right at the
beginning um through the process um
but again i i don't know the specifics
thank you mr clerk as always your
your input has been very educational i
appreciate you taking the time
thanks
okay
so with that input from
paul smith
we have these three bills
let's review what our options are we
have
10 55 which we've already voted to to
reconsider
1056 and 1057 us are still pending what
we want to do with that
one of our options that we haven't
really spoken about yet is we could itl
all three of these bills if you're
uncomfortable with
uh with moving forward and what we may
or may not get back from
on a fiscal note
we're at 10 55 we have a motion to
reconsider
saying we voted to reconsider
so at this point we're at
10 55 with a motion
to otp
as amended
so now the question is
okay
representative
may i speak to that motion yeah thank
you um
i'm going to
recommend that we
um
i don't know the proper terminology but
basically that we vote no to otpa
so that we can take on another motion
the burden that all of these will have
and i know i'm supposed to speak to this
one particular one
and i apologize my notes here somewhere
but when we when we look at the total
burden
based on 2020
of the shift of taxes we're looking at
55 million 627 thousand dollars that we
are taking from one group of people to
another group of people just in these
three bills alone
um it's it's
a lot to ask for people when we keep
talking about workforce housing bringing
younger people in and so on
so i think that we do need to
turn this particular vote around so that
we can bring
another motion
on
and give
some equal benefits to all of them well
it it pains me it truly does pay me
to vote any of these down
because these are well-deserving groups
of people i fear what we're doing to the
alternate groups of people
um so i would like you to
consider voting no on the ought to pass
with the amendment thank you
and and let me go ahead representative
thank you mr chair i have a question for
representative klee um when you got that
figure of 55 million can you describe
the process of how you
got to that number
go ahead thank you thank you sir sure um
i have it right in front of me here
if you go to the dra website
and you look at each of the individual
reports the very last
column in the bottom will tell you what
the statewide
tax loss is you can actually when you
pull up the alpha you can see by
community and that is if i just bring
this up correctly so for instance the
one that i have right in front of me
right now
is the veterans exemption and tax
credits they don't refer to that one as
taxes lost they actually refer to that
one as the credits because that's an
obvious taxes loss would be more for
those that were doing the
um exemptions
so in this particular one i bring it up
it's 2020
and i go all the way down to the very
very bottom of that report it says
statewide totals
there were
31 million 775
in tax shift is the best way i can refer
to it as but they refer to the total
amount of tax
credits granted if i went over to
let's see the
i think this is the
um
the elderly and i would look at that the
very last column towards the bottom is
called taxes lost and if i look at the
very very bottom
i will see that it was 23 million 228
of tax shift or tax loss as they refer
to it
each one of these has their alpha
if you just were to google new hampshire
tax exemptions and credits it will come
up and you can find it that way
and then it gives it in
county
it gives it in
alpha you can get in a spreadsheet or
you can get in a pdf form
you're welcome
yes representative power
thank you mr chair would i be correct in
stating that the the numbers that
representative klee just shared from the
dra website
that
in fact the numbers would be higher
due to the fact that this bill is
proposing
higher numbers
uh i'm not sure if they'd be higher or
lower
yes i do they they would in fact be be
higher because more people would fall
into those categories
um and those so for instance if we were
just to take something like the veterans
one where we're changing from 50 to 200
all those communities ahead 50 as long
as they maintain it they're going to be
giving more money so yes these numbers
will in fact go up and be higher elderly
credit if we take into 60
into consideration versus 65 as it
stands now we're adding more people to
that group so yes in fact it will go up
thank you mr chair um
i'd like to just
state for my own understanding and
possibly
for others as well that
as it was previously mentioned
towns and cities are already able to
grant these exemptions
and many many of them already do
and so if we were to vote itl on this
reconsideration motion it would not be
like we were taking
any exemption or credit away from anyone
we would simply be
hold
stopping the train in the station until
we can get better data which i think is
the responsible thing to do and i'd also
just like to put in a word
we talk a lot about attracting younger
people to the state but i'd like to put
in a word for those of us who are not
young
and for those of us who are struggling
to pay our property taxes that go up
every year relentlessly and that that
just you know do not fall into any one
of these categories and i know many
people in my community
who are in their 60s 70s and 80s who can
no longer stay in their homes
because of this shifting and raising of
property taxes and the combination of
those two things
is
you know it's it's a killer for older
people
so that's
thank you
okay
uh okay we're at this point we're at
back to
hb 1055
and we have a motion on the table to otp
as
amended um
yes
uh that motion's already been passed
right i don't know what
right we're we're in the reconsider
point are we gonna reconsider the vote
and so we're going to reconsider the uh
the last vote we took
so
uh is there a motion to be made a new
so we have a recommendation rather a
motion ought to pass as amended
right
yes you're all with me
all right so uh
mr clerk if you would call the roll i
just need who who made that motion
thank you
so we're now voting on otp as amended
the motion was made by representative
heir and and seconded by representative
tripp
vice chairman pia monty
no
black votes yes
representative
no
representative los alas
representative rhodes
no
representative melvin no
representative here no
representative power
representative 11 no
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
representative no
and uh chairman dolan no
mr chair yes i'd like to make a motion
that we itl house bill 1055. just a sec
though let's get the uh
the vote from the
17 to two
itl
motion's been made and seconded
did you get uh
please a second
no i've gotta give some more forms
you need some more papers
the motion is to itl
the motion was made by pia monte and
gilman
now by the way while the clerk is
arranging us papers if we
fyi if we itl this bill there'll be no
mr chairman yes
would it be in order
if we send it to the floor with an itl
recommendation
in the meantime ask for
information as the clerk had said with
the with the impact not a fiscal note
but just the impact
and then would it
if we wanted to on the floor
we could have a
uh we could
uh
vote down the itl motion
and
pass an otp motion
i believe that an itl vote kills the
bill
i stand corrected it can be overturned
on the floor so so it would be possible
if if you had really strong feelings
about this
and if the fiscal impact to
the municipalities
was minimal
then we could bring it up on the floor
explain it
and then
based upon the feeling of the house we
could pass it
that's an excellent idea representative
los alas
i think that's what we all want to
to just have the information so we can
make a well-informed decision
yes and to follow up on your earlier
comment
representatives davis i
i'm old
a veteran and crippled i i don't know
whether to say i'm sorry or
congratulations
it's all in your mind
mr chair yes
but because we are idealing here in our
committee we have to request for the
financial whatever the fiscal note or
impact information so that you know you
can fight it on the floor
with the information
every representative
thank you mr chair i'm not sure
necessarily that we have to
ask for
an impact statement as such i think
whoever is going to speak to it
on the floor if they decide that they
want to speak to it as an ought to pass
they could bring up those facts and
figures and so on and if they wanted to
give it to their
to all of the members that would be
you know they could be sent to them
through whoever but
i don't know if we necessarily have to i
think it's more of us individual who's
ever going to speak to do our homework
okay any other input yes representative
i just have a i guess a question
we may have some other bills that are
very similar to these tax
credits whatever you want to call them
is it going to be the policy of this
committee now that we're going to have
to get financial
records of cost in order to pass these
well it's not not a policy it's a it
would be a decision based on what the
committee wants at that particular time
well i just think it's a shame that
we've been here for a couple of hours
and uh
there's been plenty of opportunity up
prior to the executive session to try to
request this information
uh
i'm just i'm just disappointed i'm not
disappointed on the vote of the bill i'm
just uh disappointed that we didn't get
some heads up or we could have gotten
investigated this and get this
information
prior to the uh by today's meeting
thank you representatives davis but with
respect we we did request it
and we're told that it had to wait till
the executive session to be voted on we
did request it when the bills were first
heard
do i have a motion
when you have a motion of itl
um i'm ready to take a vote on that
motion
mr clerk please call the roll for itl on
yes
clerk votes yes
representative tripp yes
uh yes
representative melvin yes
representative here
representative power
yes
uh representative
representative gilman yes
representative majori yes
representative davis yes
representative mega pooty yes
representative
representative gallagher
yes
representative
eighteen to one yeah the itl passes okay
it looks like while we're stuck in the
mud there for a while looks like we're
starting to gain some traction
all right house bill 1056
which is relative to veterans tax
credits
no discussion mr clerk if you would take
the a vote on reconsideration of 1056.
if i can just get through the motion
yeah take your time where the people
were
there
the motion was made by representative
klee
oh sorry representative van gaan okay
and uh
representative
was it you was it you
256.
okay yeah motion to reconsider
house bill 1056.
vice chairman pmrt
yes click votes yes representative tripp
yes representative guthrie
representative silas yes
representative rhodes
yes
representative melvin
representative
representative power
representative majori
yes
uh representative
representative gentleman yes
representative davis yes representative
yes
representative
representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
yes representative yes
and chairman dolan
yes
what should we consider passes 19 to
zero
no representative got three half oh i'm
sorry well my apologies uh 18 to one
yes
monte what made the motion and
representative lasalla seconded so wait
a minute with the previous bill
didn't we have to first take the otpa
motion again and then do the itl motion
or
reconsider
that
mr chairman yes uh representative
gallagher is correct
uh when you when you vote to reconsider
you have to first vote on the
immediate past
motion which in this case was ought to
pass so what we have on the floor is
ought to pass and i urge people to vote
no
okay made who made the second on that
one
is there a new motion to be made well
it's no it's the old motion we're back
to octopath
yes and i urge everyone to vote no on
otp so that another motion can be made
thank you mr clerk would you call a role
for the next one
myself
okay the original motion was
representative mcdonald
and the second was
i don't remember with a second los alas
okay
so now we're voting on
whether we're going to otp
1056.
right
okay otp 1056. uh
vice chairman p.m monty
no
clickfunnels no
representative tripp no
representative guthrie
yes
uh representative silas
no
representative rhodes no
representative melvin no
representative here
representative power no
representative 311 no
representative gilman
no
representative majorie no
representative stavis no
representative man caputi
no
representative
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
representative run no
18 to one
okay now we're back to
uh
a new motion that's going to be needed
now on hb 1056.
yeah i'd like to make a motion
second
motion has been made and seconded
is there any further discussion on this
yes representative tripp
uh it's been mentioned that uh
the uh increasing the standard veterans
tax credit from
fifty dollars to two hundred dollars
would be a violation of the constitution
and it in that it downshifts
uh an increase in tax credits
uh
for the towns
so this is just another further reason
not to
i think none
mr clerk can i take a
role
on the itl motion
for 1056.
okay itl 1056. uh
repetitive representative pia monty
yes
click votes yes
representative tripp yes
representative guthrie
okay
representative los alas
yes
representative rhodes
representative melvin
yes representative
representative power yes
representative majori
yes
uh representative trey levin yes
representative gilman
representatives davis yes
representative megafooty yes
representative fan
representative clee yes
representative gallagher
yes representative ron yes
chairman dolan yes
will that uh
consent
yeah that that will go on the consent
mr chairman we'll have a report uh for
that i think representative klee agreed
to the report
yes
okay we had uh representative piamonte
as the
made the motion and representative van
seconded so we're going to have
okay well moving on to hb 1057
which we originally had otp'd that
no we haven't taken any vote on it no so
this would be a good chance to do itl to
begin with so we don't have to go
through this
process we are pretty well versed mr
chair there's an amendment to this one
may i interrupt for just one moment
please
i think that we all need to give um
maybe not a loud one but a quiet golf
clap to our clerk who has done yeoman's
labor this morning
okay now we're looking at a
what
okay
we beat that one to death
all right
uh let's take let's take a roll mr clark
okay uh itl
1057.
um vice chairman pmit yes
click forts
uh representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative losalis yes
representative rhodes yes
representative melvin
representative here
representative power yes
representative majori
yes
representative yes
representative gilman yes
representatives davis yes representative
megaputi yes
representative vann
representative klee
representative gallagher
yes representative yes
and chairman dolan yes
let's let it be known that if any of the
members of the committee want to hear
fiscal info on those three bills we just
exact
they will not be coming from the
chairman or
the speaker's office you'll have to
request that information yourself and
present it as part of your discussion on
the
on the house floor
since all three of these bills were idl
was everybody clear on that yes
representative davis i would just like
to um thank the chair
for leading us through this thicket
that just could have
gone
really sideways and it didn't because of
your leadership so thank you mr chain
well thank you i appreciate that
mr chair
yes
um all three of them are going on
consent calendar we'll have to
make you know only if it is pulled off
the consent right it'll come for a
discussion right correct
we try to put things on consent that are
17 to 2 or better yeah
thank you thank you mr chair and i again
i want to echo my colleagues
your leadership today's
really truly a good process where we had
a good debate thank you
10.69
yeah
we're gonna skip over 1070 for a minute
that's the uh the gun stock area
commission's bill
1078 is is there a motion for 1078 from
representative mcdonnell
yes i believe there's a an amendment
there also right we will
have to take up the amendment as well
make a motion to pass the amendment
otpa the amendment mr chair we don't
have the amendment i don't have any
right no that's 170.
it's not 178.
do we have the amendment
1078 the amendment is
okay
well let's uh let's get a copy of it and
spread it around okay mr chairman yeah
excuse me
i'm totally confused are we taking up
the gun stock bill now which is 10.78
right
so
does 1078 have an amendment or is it
only 10.70
that happens we're talking about 10.78
and it does happen
i'm told it has an amendment i don't
have it in front of me
i thought that was 10.70 that happened
yeah well you do have an amendment on
1070 also i i don't think we have one on
1078.
that's good
yes thank you mr chair i have a
procedural question with regard to
committees in executive session
is it the responsibility of the
obtain these amendments via email and
print them out on their own and bring
them in or is it the
procedure of the committee to provide a
printed
copy of the amendment when we come into
the executive session
yes
yes to what
yes to both
uh
we typically get those
when we enter the meeting
but
i understand that some of these come
very late in the process so we're going
to take the time if if one of us has the
amendment
to make sure it gets passed around so we
mr sheriff i might add on to that
typically we get
the amendments from the sponsor and
they're obligated to print it out for us
yes
thank you okay so so we took
so we get them from heather
or we get them off the table in the
corner where the pink cards reside
or
we get them
ahead of time in our emails so there's
multiple ways that these amendments are
distributed and i think i'd like to make
sure that responsibility lies with us
collectively to point out the fact that
someone has an amendment and someone
doesn't and we can stop and make sure we
all are on the same page yes
representative wrong
mr chair i'd like to respectfully
request that our committee adopt a
standard where whoever is sponsoring the
amendment i mean it could be the sponsor
of the bill it could be someone else
that it's their responsibility to
provide a hard copy before our meetings
our executive sessions um i don't know
about all of you but my email is packed
and it it would be easy for me to
overlook an email that contained an uh
an amendment attachment
so it's much easier to have it available
you know at the executive session thank
you i understand what you're saying your
the
committee
is in charge of the bill now
so it's their responsibility
to
supply an amendment or somebody from the
committee to
enter that amendment um they can
talk with the sponsor
but once the sponsor cannot come up and
say okay i have an amendment here has to
be one person from this committee
the the uh
let me echo that the the uh
that once we're in executive session
we own the bills we own the bill and we
on any amendments associated with the
bills
so uh
i and that's why i want to leave the
door as far open as i can
to get all
and any amendments that are
available to us yes representative
thank you chairman uh chairman i sent
you an amendment for hb 1177 i sent it
to you and i sent it to representative
maggiore
two weeks ago so
should i assume that that is going to
appear in hard copy tomorrow or should i
bring
enough copies when i come in tomorrow
because we're executing that bill
tomorrow
i would say if you make that assumption
you have about a 50 chance of it okay so
it sounds like the answer is i should
bring in my own hard copies tomorrow as
a backup i think you should okay thank
yeah i just want to um address uh
representative piamonte's
statement i actually have an amendment
in a committee for a bill that i'm not
even on um it was a germain bill for
something a constituent brought up so i
i assume the responsibility of getting
that amendment drafted printed and
distributed to the community members so
there is that other way of getting
amendments and it doesn't have to come
through the committee right
a case like that i would hope that
there's a co-sponsor associated with
that bill that you can hand that off to
that and make it easier for you so you
don't have to
miss one committee to help another
committee
yeah yeah i made the sponsor aware that
i was going to piggyback on his bill
i would just respectfully
ask or suggest that is it too difficult
just to have these amendments printed
and on the table when when we come in it
just seems very round about you know
this person that person
i'll reinforce that with heather and
you all can help if you know about an
amendment coming you can
you can
make sure she knows about it so that
when we get to that particular point of
the of the
process the bill will be there on the
table yes representative
representative truleven yes oh
mr chair
i just want to let you know that this
amendment is from the sponsor one of the
sponsors of the bill
he did email it to us and heather has
no record in her
yeah that's what that's why i've been
saying
that that i don't want to shut off any i
hear you
if one of us has it has it
that's unfortunate but at least we can
spread it from there if we all have it
better
if we have it from heather that's one uh
then you know
yeah so
so i i'm i don't want to try to penalize
any of the sponsors
uh or interested parties by
not hearing an amendment because i i
don't have it
yes representative maturi
mr chair i made a copy of the amendment
it should have pleased the chair and the
committee i can go make copies for
everybody please
thank you
mr chair yes
i have an email from tara albert virtual
listening
good morning i apologize for sending an
email to everyone in the group however
i'm not sure who this applies to
microphones are on and clicking of pens
is extremely distracting when trying to
follow along with the hearing thank you
tara albert solid waste operator
training and certification coordinator
just it caught my attention so i'm just
bringing it to the thanks all right well
thanks for that input uh let's be
mindful of the fact that if our
microphones are on we have to uh
adhere to some amount of level of
silence they don't need to be in a cone
of silence but you should understand
that
our actions comments whispers
noises
are picked up by these microphones which
are very sensitive
mine is the one that stays on all the
time but if if you're if you're going to
speak you should turn your microphone on
and then when you're done turn it off
please
okay
so we are looking at uh
1078 which is
which is a
recommendation for budget procedures at
gun stock we're going to get
an updated
amendment that's coming to us from the
office
but in the meantime do we have a motion
on 1078 we'll make sure that we don't
have any discussion until uh
oh for the amendment i see what you're
saying
you want to move on to the next one and
i'm sorry sir unless it's a general
information we're not taking input from
yeah prove the amendment and then
you
representative matthew will you make
sure that
right
oh yeah i
england
yes
for those of you
doing a quick read on what was just
handed to you i understand that two
i don't see representative silver here
will it be somebody
presenting
um
i used to have a policy when i was chair
that one of the members would have to
bring forward an amendment just for that
reason so they could talk to it because
we couldn't bring other people in that's
why it makes it more i'll be asking for
so we are
now for those of you in the audience who
have been very patient
house bill 1078 which is
relative to budget procedures for the
okay uh
representative mcdonald do you have a
motion
h
motion has been made to adopt the
amendment before us is there a second
is the discussion about this amendment
before we move forward yes
representative
i'm going to vote in opposition to the
amendment just because i think it
requires input by the commission members
and people we heard testimony from
um
i i
you know i'm disappointed this bill even
came forward i wish that commission was
in hillsborough county they're so
successful i think if it's not broken
don't fix it
and any amendment that even addresses
that without input from
um the stakeholders i i just i i would
not be able to accept it thank you thank
you any further discussion yes
representative lee
thank you mr chair i i think during the
testimony i had asked a question as to
whether or not they had been
presented
with budgets and so on and asked for
input and
i think at one point it was quite quite
confusing because certain people said no
um and then i believe we got a follow-up
email that showed us that they had in
fact been doing
what had been asked of them and what we
would expect of them so for that reason
i i have to vote no on this as well
thank you by the way is there anybody on
the committee that would like to step
forward and explain this amendment to
representative
thank you mr chair
um being mindful of the fact that um
i used to hang out with somebody who was
employed by the gun stock ski area
and of the fact that i haven't been able
to attend meetings in person until today
i'm very grateful to be here i've been
reading
and following along and but the salient
point for me is that i listened to the
radio this morning on the way in and
people
of the state of new hampshire many of
whom are probably from belknap county
spoke up in opposition to any changes to
the
financial or fiscal situation in or the
commissioner situation at gun stock
wanted to point that out thank you
any further discussion yes
representative piemonte mr move the
question and make a motion to accept
amendment
2 0 2 2
motions are made to accept the amendment
as provided
yes
i'm sorry oh
you did i'm sorry
so the motion's been made
and
who's second in depth
representative ayer
all right so now we have
hb 1078
uh
amended so let's take a vote on the
amendment
vice chairman pmrt yes
click votes yes
representative tripp
yes representative guthrie yes
los alas yes representative mcbride
i'm sorry uh representative rhodes yes
thank you uh representative melvin
yes
representative
representative power yes
uh representative mijori
no
representative tray 11 no
representative
gilman
no
representative davis no
representative mega poody
no
representative
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
representative no
and chairman dolan yes
motion adopt the amendment is
okay so we have uh before us
an adopted amendment for hb 1078 and now
we're going to take a take a see if we
have a motion on how to dispose of 1078
is there a motion
yes i have a motion
motion has been made to itl is it second
is there any discussion
on that motion
yes representative um mr chair just uh
there was not just the opposition of
1200 folks online opposition to this
bill there was 2 3 500 signature
petition against this bill that the
people that testified
demonstrated
or expressed
and this is from the belknap county
voters so there is a big
opposition to this from the county
voters or the citizens so just heating
to that
you know itl is the right motion for us
thank you is there further discussion on
uh vice chairman pmrt
yes
clerk votes yes
uh representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative asalis
yes representative rhodes
yes
representative melvin yes representative
representative majori
yes
representative power
uh representative eleven
yes
representative gilman
representatives davis yes
representative megapootie
yes
representative vann
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
yes representative ryan
yes
and chairman dolan yes
uh motion ito passes 19-0 okay without
objection i'll put that in the consent
calendar
and i have a confession to make i think
i may be the guilty party of clicking
i'll
yes thank you
mr chair do you need a report on that
from the dems or or are is the are the
republicans going to submit one on the
gun stock bill 1078 yes sir yes that
will be a report will be written by
yeah this came up i think last year
when we had these 19-0 votes
votes that uh
what's the need to write a committee
report and
i took that to the same gentleman that
we spoke to earlier mr smith and uh
the answer is we write a report on
everything
mr chairman yes
you do need a report in case it gets
taken off consent you need to have this
the
our side of it right
okay
we're going to next move on to the
uh
the dissolution of a village district
all right all right okay i'm sorry
the next bill we're going to take up is
hb 1087
relative to zoning to single family
we have a motion
um
emotions made to itl seconded by
discussion on the on the motion
yes representative davis
um so i support this bill
because uh it it does what we all have
said in various hearings and testimonies
that we want to do which is to keep the
rural parts of new hampshire rural
and increase housing for single family
homes
in those areas where they are served by
public water and sewer and that is
exactly what this bill does
and so therefore i support it in the
hopes that will be one other small step
forward in trying to combat the housing
crisis that we custom that we currently
have
while not changing the rural character
of our state
thank you mr chairman
this is a
a great idea but in my community we have
a master plan
and
our water and silver is pretty much
maxed out
uh
and if we put in
four houses in one acre lots that are
supposed to be one one house we're going
to be talking probably 25 30 million
dollars to
upgrade our sewer treatment plant
again i think it's a great idea but it's
just
it's it's
be too taxing on my community to support
this bill to change our master plan to
go from maybe four single dwellings to
16 residents
representative
thank you
mr chairman
this is does not specify for four homes
or anything it changes lot sizes which
allows
more homes and create density but i have
to agree that
i i think it would be best to allow each
of the municipalities to determine
how they need to create their own
master plan and i can say in nashville
we have a master plan as well and there
are certain areas that are zoned to do
something that would effectively
kill six of nashua's current zoning
so i i can't support this i think each
municipality should have their own say
thank you
represents davis
i would just like to follow up by saying
that the bill specifically says that the
watts cannot exceed existing municipal
or community water and sewer
infrastructure
any any further comments is
representative fan
yes chairman thank you
and i'd also like to remind everyone
that
state statute allows the community to
say you can't do this thing because it
does in fact exceed our capacity it's
called scattered and premature
so again again the bill says
you don't have to enact this if your
current water and sewer doesn't allow it
and even if you don't know that and you
find it out
the existing statute would allow you to
to deny it
and i'd also like to add
we've waited for 40 years for individual
towns to allow historically appropriate
density i did a survey of a town in new
hampshire pretty ordinary town in new
hampshire to determine what the actual
historic lot size was
and in peterborough the actual historic
lot size is less than a quarter of an
acre
it's about ads between 6 000 and 8 000
square feet in the part of town that
does in fact have water and sewer so i
just offer that
as information that historically
this is a
not too far off from what our existing
lot sizes are and that decisions that
were made over the last 50 60 years to
require larger lots in an effort to
manage growth
actually have given us
a form of growth that is not
not sustainable
as
representatives davis pointed out it
spreads development into the rural
district because if you can't
use a small lot in the center of town
you have to go to the outside and
when you create larger lots
outside of town
you are also committing the town to the
maintenance of those roads which as i
say every time i talk about roads costs
us 4.65
a center line foot every year
for every foot of roads to salt sand
plow ditch and mow and that is not
including building the thing or repaving
it when the time comes
so i am in favor of this bill for all
those reasons because it does allow the
towns to opt out if their infrastructure
won't support it
and it encourages historically
appropriate density
in the parts of town that do have
services thank you additional discussion
mr chairman
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
say that
uh as a selectmen when i see shell
require in any bill
uh i i really get concerned about that
because
i i
every one of our towns in new hampshire
are a little bit different and
a shoe doesn't fit everybody
every foot so
i i was concerned about that and then
when i see that
although the bill is well intended and
we do have a housing pro
problem but i think there's there's too
many
uh
individual town difficulties when you
designate it a hundred square foot lot
size for single family home
i i think it's a good idea i would like
to see it
in
my community my community is hampstead
is mostly all built up
and unfortunately as far as the housing
problem is concerned we have more three
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
homes
than we probably can justify with the
way things are now but i can't fit vote
for this bill mainly because
to do a particular planning that they
can do on their own if they wish and i
don't think the state should be telling
them
thank you any further discussion mr
chair
yes
thank you mr chair um i am in support of
this bill
i want to bring some attention to the
online
support and oppose there were 23 support
and seven opposing
and
when we have such acute shortage just in
my city we have 5
unit shortage
so we have to you know we just cannot
keep saying we are not going to do
anything this is going to affect
and it does give the municipalities and
that rural towns to
do what's best for their community it
it's
so
if we don't do anything we are driving
workforce
housing workforce from our state
out and it's an economic
engine
that drives our state's economy so with
that in mind
i will support this because we need
more housing thank you thank you
representative
the primary reason i'm against this
is because
this would create a statewide mandate
it removes
the uh
the ability of the local planning
land use planning
to create ordinances that fit
the uh needs and desires of the uh towns
that they exist in
uh i'm going to vote no on this bill
thank you
additional comments
yes representative lasallus
i would just like to
make a comment that
following up on uh representative van's
comment about the
uh you know
the fact that we've been waiting for
individual towns to
to uh
make these changes
and and i agree with that uh issue i
would say that
just this morning
i heard that the market is beginning to
respond
to the need for housing they're they're
turning a uh
major um
office
uh building in manchester into
residential
uh that's happening
so uh
the
uh the market the free market is
responding to this
uh whether it'll occur i'm i'm not
afraid of
of this for a small town like mine
because
we don't have sewer and water so
you know it doesn't impact us from that
standpoint
but
what is impacting us
is the great need for housing
generally
and that is coming
into
even
rural areas
so
at this point i don't know how i'm going
to vote but i'll make up my when the
time comes okay thank you
any additional comments yes
representative
thank you mr chair and to my friend from
litchfield i i agree with everything
that you said and
we'll be
voting in support of this against
against a couple of different
suggestions to vote itl on this bill
i am opposed to the shall in most
instances i am
i'm opposed to the
camel's nose under the tent where where
i see it might happen but this one is so
specific
to the communities that have municipal
water and sewer it's not going to affect
northampton we we don't have it
it's not going to affect many of the
seacoast communities
that are favorable but but i do
i i do
not generally like the idea of
mandates but to representative van's
point
we've got to do something
we've got to do something so thank you
seeing none we have a motion on the
floor by representative guthrie
to itl this bill
and seconded by representative ayer
seeing no further discussion mr
clerk would you take the role okay itl
on 1087 uh vice chairman pmrt
yes public votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative salas
yes
representative rhodes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majorie
no
representative
representative gilman no
representative stavis no
representative megapootie
no
representative vann
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
no
representative rung no
okay at this point i'm gonna we're gonna
take a break for lunch i'd like to ask
that you all come back by
yes we're gonna
in the meantime
representative guthrie we're gonna ask
you to write the committee report
okay thank you
everybody
all
you
all right let's start up we're going to
take the uh
the next bill we're going to talk to for
the executive
1098.
all right
yes
we have anybody willing to introduce
chairman i'm willing to introduce it
do you have an amendment
there is an amendment and i'm willing to
to present it
okay please do okay so this is an
amendment the house bill 1098 which um
has
to do with the number of off-street
parking spaces required per occupied
dwelling
and the amendment replaces what was
originally proposed by representative
yokolov with
entirely new language and it says
674 colon 23 cola dash a zoning
restrictions on parking spaces the local
legislative body shall not
adopt ordinances requiring more than one
off-street parking space per occupied
dwelling
um and i'm happy to talk about this
minute
if you want me to the amendment
yeah it came with the hearing it's what
was presented as at the hearing
he came in with this amendment
all right let's formalize this up a
little bit uh
let's see if we have a motion
on 1098
uh mr uh representative ayer do you have
is there a second ito
i i think we have to adopt the amendment
first
okay we could just we could just kill
the bell and ignore the advent amendment
that's one thing we do but i i have a
tendency to want to include
rather than exclude so i've got i'm
going to go
look for a motion to
to open the the bill and then we'll well
we'll take a motion to
either
add the amendment or
all right um i will say that the prime
sponsor
uh did present the amendment to us at
the time of the original hearing if that
makes a difference to us
i do remember that
um so i'm happy to make an emotion
that we
uh adopt the the amendment
and
we can make a decision on that and then
we can vote on the underlying bill okay
is there is there a second on uh
otp on the amendment right and then
we'll take up the whole bill
after we've got a second on that motion
yes
representative van do you have the
number of the amendment
it is
[Music]
thank you zero six one zero h
here we have a motion on the amendment
and it's been seconded is there a
discussion on the amendment
yes representative
um
eric
gallagher
um so
to be clear as to what the amendment
does it basically just inserts the words
it inserts off street
not on street oh okay i think because
what it's he's what the what the
amendment and the underlying bill both
seek to do
is to restrict the number of off-street
parking spaces that can be required for
any individual dwelling unit
more discussion on the on the amendment
representative van do you want to talk
about it some more
i'm happy to say that i think that
parking regulations are a huge problem
in terms of housing however i do not
recommend that we adopt the bill because
i think it does not
this isn't let's
so
why
why are we doing this first of all
i just don't get it are we regulating
traffic in manchester or
uh are we not allowing people to buy a
second car and have one placed in an
area you know i mean let's let's
narrow this to
i can actually respond
i want to narrow it to the amount this
this is the amendment that he's asking
about uh i did not bring this bill but i
can tell you that
uh the underlying idea here was
that when a jurisdiction
requires
excessive parking
that it it costs more money to build
that building
and it uses up land that could be used
for housing
so wait i i am not in favor of this
either the amendment or the bill because
i don't think this is the way to manage
it
but that's the underlying theory behind
it if you take a car space is about 200
square feet so if you require two off
street parking spaces and you have to
have a drive aisle you're now at about
750 square feet
for parking for that unit which is
in a lot of cases
another unit
so that's the the theory behind it i
don't think this is the way to do it
okay so we have a motion on the
on the floor to uh
to adopt this amendment as presented
okay mr clark
is justifying another meeting if you
give me all right he's going to oh yeah
mr clerk would you call the role the
motion was otp on the amendment yes
so we have a motion of otp
on amendment two zero two two zero six
one zero h to house bill
1098 vice chairman
yes
no
um representative mcbride
no it's not here correct right
there we go representative i'm sorry
roads no
representative melvin no
representative
representative power no
um i'm acting as the clerk so
representative majority no
representative true levin no
representative gilman no
representative stavis no representative
manager poody no representative vann
representative klee
no representative gallagher
yes
representative wrong
no mr chair the motion fails
i'm going to count that and so it is
okay so now we have
the bill 1098
is there an alternate motion that
mr chair i just want to have a point of
order
um
speaking as my
years as a clerk on another committee
that motion we previously had is is
actually adopting the amendment we don't
pass an amendment so it's just
on the form it should just say you
should check where it says adopt
amendment thank you right so so we're
voting on 1098
not amended
i move that we find uh hb 1098
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second yes
okay representative
seconded
and mr clark if you could uh call the
roll on 1098
as uh as an itl
so the vote on another motion on house
bill 1098 is itl vice chairman pimante
yes
acting as the clerk majority votes yes
i go to representative tripp yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative rhodes
yes
representative melvin yes representative
representative power yes
representative tree levin yes
representative gilman yes representative
stavis yes representative banja puti yes
representative vann
representative klee yes representative
gallagher
no representative wrong yes
mr chair the motion of itl passes
yes you still want to vote
i'm really trying to get you out of this
but
so still even with that vote
the motion is 17-1 mr chair thank you
and without objection i'll
okay
all right the next uh
order of
our business is going to be to take up
house bill 1070
which is relative to the default budget
in official ballot jurisdictions
so
representative
lasales do you have a motion
yes
yes mr chairman i would like to uh
uh
make a motion that we pass
um
house bill 1070.
i'd like to second that
okay we have a
we have an amendment to uh
the 1070.
the amendment
okay you should also have a copy of the
amendment do you do not have a copy
if you want we can stop and get a copy
this
this is
so we have a motion
to pass
we're getting ready to get
okay so uh we have a motion and a second
amendment uh
there's a motion on the floor
representative lasales will you withdraw
your
emotion
all right so now we have an amendment to
consider
on
is there a motion to pass 1070.
i move we adopt
amendment 2022
0739 h to house bill
representative guthrie makes a second
second
okay so we have a motion
to otp the amendment
and
yes representative power
thank you mr chair i'd like to speak to
the amendment two zero two two zero
seven three nine h to house bill 1070.
so
this
amendment simply corrects
an error in the original bill
on line 23 of page one
there's a strikeout and that was
stricken out in error and it just puts
that back in the language that was not
intended to be
removed
yes
i have questions um representative power
maybe you can help me um when we had
testimony um specifically we had from ms
heck at the new hampshire municipal
association
it appears there were multiple
technicalities
and also from mr
nauer
he's supervisor of the municipal bureau
at dra
he also cited two court cases relative
that this would be in conflict with
court decisions made in 2016 and 2017.
i was just wondering does this only
correct that one technicality or or all
of them
and that is correct the the amendment
only addresses that
um
the strikeout on line 23. it does not
address any of those
points you raised okay
with that then i'm going to be opposed
to the amendment
okay any further discussion yes
representative
um
thank you mr chair i am
similar to representative wrong
my note says you know it only affects sb
two towns 72 of them
and if and the dra does not evaluate our
amend default budget so
there is
it's
it's going to affect
very focused specific sb2 towns and uh
in a negative way is my understanding so
i would oppose
amen any further discussion
okay seeing no further discussion we're
going to take a vote on whether or not
mr clerk you want to take a roll
thank you mr chair i promise to try to
remember you this time thank you
so the motion is ought to pass
h
and we start with
vice chair pimante
yes
clerk is non-voting and i am acting as
the clerk and i vote majority votes no
we move to representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
representative rhodes
representative melvin yes representative
ayer
representative power yes
representative
no
representative gilman no
representative stavis no representative
manjuputi no
representative vann
representative klee
no representative gallagher
uh chair dolan yes
mr chair
that puts us at nine two nine let me
double check wait one two three four
five six seven eight nine
two nine the motion fails
who's uh
who's not here from
the clerk
no from
we're 100 percent here for the democrat
yes sir
okay
so in my book that means a fail
so we'll have to uh we'll come back to
well mr mr chair mr chair i i
can we do that can we just walk away
from it
uh at this point uh
it fails
yeah the amendment failed to be adopted
so now we're on the underlying bill
we'll go you're right we'll go to the uh
um thank you mr chair
rsa 197 colon 6 refers to petition
it's not clear to me why it's in statute
you know currently the default budget no
i'm looking at the house bill 1070
i guess i'm not sure what the point
the connection between the default
budgets and what you just said yeah
exactly so
i don't understand why it's why it's
there right now if somebody could um
does anybody have a comment comment on
that further and give some other in
mr chair before this comment i just
asked you was there a disposition on
this bill
anybody have any comment for
representative power as to
we're talking about
this bill which is which is relative to
default budgets and official ballot
jurisdictions and
she has a concern about what we're
voting on well i was just going to make
a motion
mr chair i moved before we make a motion
we have to disposition what's already on
excuse me the uh adopting the amendment
was a tie so it failed so we are left
then with the bill which at this point
has no motion unless i am incorrect
mr chair
yes representative power has a question
about the bill itself
i can't answer it for you because
yes
thank you mr chair i i apologize i'm
very confused as to what we're doing and
where we are in the process so
um
ignore my my inquiry we're at house bill
and the the amendment failed
so we're back to the base bill
and uh
we're about to get a motion to
disposition the bill either otp or itl
or there's one other option
but
is you're all set
okay what's the motion now yes i move
that um
house bill 1070 is recommended for an
expedia to legislate
okay so the motion is to itl 1070 is
that yes
oh you're a second okay
any further discussion
we have a motion and a second yes
representative to sell us
i think this bill
is gets right to the
fundamentals
of
why we have public
discussion and public
input
on
budgeting
in
sb2 towns
the situation right now
is that
in the sb2 town
a budget an operating budget is
submitted to a budget committee
the budget committee does
exhaustive work
going line item by line item in public
and going over the operating budget
if there is no control over what is in
the default budget
then all that exhaustive work
that went in by the budget committee
is
is thrown aside
if the default budget happens to be
greater
than the than the proposed operating
budget
and we've in my particular
case in our town
we have an sb2 situation
and repeatedly
time and time again
exceeds
the proposed operating budget
it's supposed to be
at fallback position in case the
operating budget
doesn't pass
so i really think that there needs to be
some sort of control
over that
that default budget so it is indeed
put back
to where it was supposed to be
thank you
further discussion yes
the jury
thank you mr chair my concern
with this bill
with this bill uh is parent three less
any reductions to an appropriation the
governing body
made in the proposed operating budget
it's a member of the select board with a
in an sb2 town that has an official
budget committee i propose my select
board proposes a budget and then hands
that to the budget committee
the default budget then would be based
on
the budget that i proposed
i see this if this bill passes as a way
for a select board
to pump that proposed budget up or or
flatten it out
with
no discretion a proposed operating
budget
so i could propose my budget's 8 million
dollars i could propose a 30 million
dollar
operating budget that then becomes a
default budget
or less it says less any reductions to
the appropriate budget excuse me so i
could go in there somebody wrote could
say i'm going to make that a three
million dollar budget
and that is the proposed budget that
goes into default
i don't see there being discretion there
i'm proposing a responsible budget
at that point that we hope then is
adopted i would like to see that being
what we are considering less or adjusted
for any one-time appropriations as the
dra has set forth in statute so my
concern is over those words proposed
operating budget it gives me grave
yes
thank you mr chair um
i have a problem with this budget you
know we've been going through default
budget uh nudges at this
sorry
uh we've been
nudging at this default budget idea for
a few years
and the idea that the default budget
negated because of circumstances such as
uh the retirement of a
uh bond in that one year
one year in the de help budget see if i
get this straight
um
a proposed budget doesn't have that bond
payment anymore
but the default budget would be based on
the current fiscal year's budget the
active budget this is taking three
different budgets to make the default
budget
so
the
sometimes the default budget will be
higher because you've retired
a debt
in your proposed budget yep but about
this particular bill
line nine
less any reduction in appropriation the
governing body made in the proposed
operating budget
totally conflicts with line 18
d
and the definition of contracts
which
contracts previously approved in the
amount so approved
so even if in your proposed budget
you're approving something less
the default budget will go back to
that year
the operating year that you're in it'll
go back to that contract price
so
you don't want it in your operating but
your proposed budget but you have to
have it because it's contract
so it's directly
it directly
i think makes a circle of the
line nine and line
eighteen
okay uh thank you
yes thank you mr chair um i agree with
what representative gilman said i'm i'm
concerned with the the technical
conflicts that this bill creates with
language that's already in statute
that's not addressed in the bill
i definitely sympathize with represent
lasalles because
merrimack is a senate bill to town and
i think for the past several years our
default budget's been greater than our
proposed operating budget
however
at the deliberative session the voters
still have they can
amend the proposed budget to be
lower and that so the voters on the
election day still have the choice of do
they want the lower
even if it's amended a deliberative
session if they want that budget amount
or the default budget so voters still
have a choice
um
and and i think you know maybe we need
to look more at the default budget to
make sure there's a clean bill that
doesn't propose conflicts
um but this this bill doesn't really um
i i don't think it's going to be
workable for
some of those reasons that
representative gilman brought up thank
you
yes question
thank you
representative
on an average how many people do you
have
uh well we have two deliberative
sessions we have one for the town and
one for the school district and it
depends what um
what what's on the warrant
i think
and if it was last year or the year
before
we had a lot of people um because there
was um
i i forget what it was representative b
monty there was something
that got the attention of people more
that they were at the deliberative
session there's been some deliberative
sessions when the the people that had to
be there the school board the budget
committee the attorney the moderator
that numbered more than they the res of
the voters coming but it really all
depends on
what's you know what is on the warrant
if there's anything specific
typically i think one year we had a
warrant article
to replace the football field with
artificial turf those kind of things
tends to draw more people but it's
yes okay i um
the default budget
for the school board the default budget
was 7 million i'd say 900 000
and the actual budget was 7 million uh
a hundred thousand dollars less so
um you know
it gave you no option
to choose
and i think that's what this bill is
in further discussion
we have a motion on the floor
to itl
it's been
seconded for any further discussion
seeing none
i'd like to ask the clerk to take a role
please
vice chair pimante
now
representative
no
yes
yes he voted yes
okay
okay so let's go to the next one we
have we've done the
village
district that's right you did this one
right bill's district
we're gonna wait on that yeah
all right the next bill we're gonna take
up is hb 11
19.
okay
so mr chair i uh move that we adopt
emotion is made to
yes um mr chair
for the committee if they remember back
to the public hearing there was some
uh question as to
garbage bags that might be purchased
like hefty garbage bags or something so
um this amendment clarifies that the
intent is
um referring to bags that are used at
the point of sale
thank you
any other discussion
yes representative
um
thank you mr chair
question to the amendment representative
who brought the amendment this will
address
the issue of our hefty
bags our single use or
not right so
making it point a sale
would be at the checkout counter correct
uh this amendment talks about plastic
bags and paper bags was that the
intention include paper bags
um i
i believe it was
it's not an ore situation plastic bags
or paper bags it's a either
plastic if if a municipality wants to
regulate the distribution of plastic
bags and paper bags they can but it one
regulating one can exclude the other
how do you interpret that that way um
let's say
i mean
you know in my town this isn't going to
apply this is enabling legislation but
suppose there's a town that wants the
the business to ask the customer do you
want a bag and if you do want a bag do
you want a plastic bag or a paper bag
that's regulating the distribution there
might be some towns that elect to ban
both paper and plastic there might be
some that choose to ban one or the other
um
it just
is if there's bags made out of plastic
or paper it gives the the municipality
the option of of regulating that at the
um
thank you mr chair isn't this the
enabling legislation which attempts to
reduce the single use
back by
uh offering the choice of bringing your
own
reusable bags at the point of sale
hence the
single use plastic or paper is not
i can't i can't speak for the sponsor
but i suspect the prime sponsor but i
suspect that was her intent
um
i signed on to this bill because it is
enabling and if you look at other things
that are in that area the statute we're
allowing municipalities to regulate
tattoo parlors and
noise and
political contributions in local
elections retail display of martial arts
weapons so
i'm thinking if municipalities why not
enable them to make a decision about
yes
i'm i'm wondering what your definition
of distribution is
would that uh uh include
i'm sorry representative yeah i i think
so i think distribution could require
sale it could be the giving of the bag
um it's just how that transfer of the
bag is made at the point of sale to the
customer that that process and anything
that would be involved in it
mr chair i have a
follow-up the reason i asked that is uh
i believe it during the testimony that
people were talking about
how they uh the paper bags was included
because there might be a
some thoughts about requiring a 10 cent
deposit on paper bags in the future so
that's i don't know if a deposit is a
sale
but uh it it would seem to limit the
distribution of paper bags so that's why
i ask is distribution just
when plastic bags are given to the
customers
or does it include sale of paper bags or
does it include just deposit on a paper
bag
i'm i'm reading the word distribution in
a broad sense so it would be inclusive
of any transaction whether it's given at
a cost or not
um
so
like i said before my my intent with
this was just to allow municipalities to
make decisions that they think are in
their best interest
yes representative
thank you mr chair uh
i think that the issue that we're trying
to do here is allow jurisdictions to
make whatever decisions so for example
under distribution i would imagine that
this would include charging you a nickel
for a paper bag
charging you a nickel for
a plastic bag
saying that we're not going to let you
use plastic bags anymore whatever the
local jurisdiction
decides among itself is reasonable
is the intent of the bill as i
understand it
and as representative brung says it's
enabling legislation each individual
town would have to decide what they
mr
thank you mr chair um i know back in uh
i'm dating back i don't know how many
years ago
grocery stores in my area would say if i
brought my own reusable bag i would get
uh five dollar five cents
of credit
at the check you know so that was an
incentive to bring my own bag
and uh but it it's not happening so this
in that enabled
the use of or reduce the use of me
getting reusable plastic or paper
so that incentive
charging five cents for a plastic bag
one time use plastic or paper
or giving five cents credit for bringing
any other discussion
i'm having a little bit of difficulty
with the base legislation it's not the
amendment because the amendment didn't
change
but it's the distribution of single-use
plastic bags and paper bags to customers
i would be more comfortable if it said
either or he gave some gave the
retailers a
an option to use one or the other not
right now the way it's written it has to
yes
mr chairman i i actually think that's
not what it says
i think what it says is individual
jurisdictions may regulate the
description descrip distribution
of
both
and that's my word single-use plastic
bags and
paper bags so a jurisdiction
and it's the jurisdiction that makes the
decision
not the retailer
the jurisdiction can decide that they
want to
legislate against the use of plastic
bags that they want to legislate against
them by requiring that
merchants charge for them
or they could legislate against paper
bags
the same way or they could legislate
that's what i think is happening here so
we're saying that and and there's an
argument to be made that paper bags are
worse than them plastic bags they're
heavier they use more materials to
produce them
they don't actually degrade as fast as
we think they do
so i think that allowing towns to make a
decision
about both plastic and paper
thank you mr chair
uh i'm going to use representatives
band's
method of parsing the the sentence to
bring up
another issue i think
she read
regulating the distribution of
single-use plastic bags
and plastic and paper bags
that sentence could also be read to
regulating the distribution of single
use
plastic bags and paper bags so does this
include single-use paper bags
yes my my reading of it
you can't get any other
any other reading out of that
all right thank you
letter q
regulating the distribution of single
paper bags and
i'd rather single-use plastic bags and
paper bags to customers i don't see you
can read it any other way other than
both are going to be
going to be uh
regulated yeah why are we discussing the
bill when we're supposed to be
discussing the amendment
what's that
here
all right never mind thank you sorry to
button
you you've now piqued my interest
mr chairman
yes
the one line is all there is and the
only change in the amendment
was to
add at the end of the sentence at point
of sale
so that it's clear that what we're
talking about is the bag you get when
you buy
your groceries or your cosmetics or
whatever it is
so we're
that's what the amendment says and
that's where we are
representative
so uh
so we are talking about single-use paper
bags
so
if there was if there's paper bags for
sale at the store other than single-use
paper bags how would you differentiate
you say that again
well since we decided that this this
bill
only limits the distribution of
single-use plastic bags and single use
paper bags
is there if there's
paper bags available at the store that
are other than single use how would the
um i'm trying to understand your
question representative
so at the point of sale
you're saying if there are paper bags
there
available that are not
um single use is that correct that's
true um
so
i you know i i'm trying to understand if
there's even anything that exists a
paper bag that exists that isn't single
use intended for single use
i mean i get single use paper bags at
some places and i reuse them
but they're not intended to be a
multi-use they're intended it's like
you know i i shop at a grocery store if
i get a single-use plastic bag
it's i i reuse that but it's not
intended to be
multi-use it's only intended to be
single use
so
i guess i'd have to
have
i'd have to be aware that multi-use
paper bags are
are
available
thank you mr chairman
this this amendment
as has been pointed out um
while we are talking about single-use
plastic prospects so
this amendment the only thing it changes
from the bill
is the words to customers
from that to at point of sale that's
really what the discussion should be i
think the and or
single use and so on should be more for
the bill itself
i think we should just discuss whether
or not the at point of sale and i think
that this amendment was just to clarify
because there was a lot of confusion
during the
the public hearing um when it said two
customers was it if customers bought
leaf bags or customers bought hefty bags
in a box and so on so this was just
talking about the the bags that
are given at a point of sale and i think
that's all this amendment really
talks about the bill itself does talk
about the and and the single use etc but
the only change from this to this is
those
very very words at the end
two customers versus at point of sale
and i think the at point of sale is the
i'm clarifying so regardless of how you
feel about the bill
to pass the amendment would at least do
clarifying and then however the bill
turns out it turns out
thank you
representative phil evan did you have a
comment representative power
thank you mr chair um my my um comment
pertained to the bill itself so i will
defer
uh representative maggiore
thank you mr chair representative klee
hit my point
did you have a comment um
i i just don't understand that they have
these
stations set up to collect the plastic
bags and they oh sorry come on yeah
collect the plastic bags and they're
using them for
say for example the tracks uh
boards that
they use for decks and stuff
i mean those are extremely expensive and
why wouldn't we not uh
use these uh
collection stations
more uh
frequently than and they know i know
it's up to an individual
but why wouldn't they be
used more often than not you know i mean
i don't see
if if they're promoted for right even at
the transfer stations they could put a
10-yard dumpster or an 8-yard dumpster
there specifically for those
and
i think it would be a good
avenue
instead of
thank you mr chair
oh boy this feels like deja vu all over
again
um in the last session we had
a plastic bag ban bill that was
essentially
the same as this one except that it was
not enabling legislation it was a
statewide ban on the use of single
plastic bags
um
this is fundamentally different because
it's just enabling the fact of the
matter is that
cities and towns could probably do this
already if they wanted to it just would
make it easier when interacting with
retail outlets if there was something in
statute that enabled them to do it if
they so ch chose to do it
we are not talking about instituting a
plastic or paper ban
bag ban
we are simply talking about allowing
municipalities to choose to go that
route if their voters wish to do
so any further discussion yes
representative
is it appropriate for me to call the
question
um
it's appropriate but i may not choose to
uh correct it
live to call the question okay
i i hear you but i want to make sure
that we have completed our discussion on
this this is a
rather controversial can be
controversial
um
i don't know i drive around quite a bit
and
i think in
all
i mean i i just don't see these plastic
bags causing
uh so much pollution and things like
that i mean we had someone last year
police from the the river
um
you know
i think i saw one
in a tree in the wintertime
one
and it boils down to the fact that
you know
people are basically responsible you
have some that are irresponsible and
those are the ones that are going to
pollute with these plastic bags
but
you know maybe increasing the fines on
them or something like that maybe an
alternative than then putting a border
i'm putting a an order fin that it's
mandatory to use plastic bags
i don't uh i don't think that this isn't
mandatory this is enabling sorry
this is not mandatory on anyone
you have to i'm sorry mr question
i'm
sorry to be so formal but we
we
lose our
thank you mr chair
um
with with due respect this is not a
mandate
it was the mandate in the last session
that went down in flames
this is enabling legislation it's simply
a if you want to
you might consider
but it is simply not a ban
you know
it's on the way to the
next session you get a ban on it you
know what i mean
so why even open the door now
you know is what i'm getting there
uh
we had a comment is it representative
wrong
yeah i just wanted to address mr
piamonte's concern um i i think we
we have to look at the bill at the face
value it's enabling legislation i voted
against the statewide ban
that bill
um i don't think i i i i'll pretty much
bet this would never fly in merrimack
but i'm not going to assume that i know
better than other communities
other communities in merrimack 2 we have
a lot of responsibility on solid waste
management and we have we spend a lot of
money on solid waste management
and we hear in testimony how sometimes
these bags cause expensive repairs on
the um
the sorting machines and stuff
merrimack would probably absorb that
repair cost but there might be a town
that doesn't i want them to be enabled
to make this decision if they want to if
they don't want to like my town they
won't but it just it's enabling
legislation
i and i you know i want to reiterate
that we need to be careful about
presuming that we know what's best for
other for communities i think they know
what's best for themselves
representative
yeah one of the things that came up in
testimony was that portsmouth has i
believe it was portsmouth has in fact
enacted
a
bag
ruling about what kind of bags they can
use and they did it
knowing that they were way out on the on
the you know tippy end of the branch and
maybe there was not statutory authority
to do that so what this does is
gives those communities which wish to do
that the statutory authority to do so
thank you mr chair um two responses one
to representative piermantes the
recycled decking plastic decking
that each community has chosen how to do
their recycling if it is a single stream
these plastic bags can contaminate the
stream and the whole recycling
of
bulk is rejected
and some communities do sort it and
that's more expensive but it
hopefully cl you know gives them a
cleaner
stream of recycled plastic and these
single use plastic bags
do
lend itself for that particular
recycling and vermont our neighboring
state vermont does that
having said that
this is an enabling legislation gives
each community to
choose how they want to do it in
nashville we have a mixed stream and we
have you know we've been doing recycling
curbside but mixed stream has created
some
issues because the recycled material is
being rejected because of some mixed
especially the plastics and don't
put everything in one
so
i think this at least helps
each communities to be responsible for
their own
ways solid waste
and also i want to bring people's
attention
to online support and oppose i know it's
a small number but 118
in support of this bill and 11 in a
position so there is a need or at least
the citizens have spoken to some extent
in my view thank you
thank you additional comments
representative tripp
i know this is going down on a limb but
uh
would you consider
the plastic bags that
well i use them to put dirty shoes in
but uh
so again i'm getting used no they're not
well i i do believe that
plastic bags that bread comes in are
single-use bags and they are at the
point of sale so that's not what we're
my last comment is that
the mixed stream issue is definitely an
issue and i know in my community
these types of bags in your
recycling buckets
what happens at the recycling center
they reject the entire bucket and they
and the community gets an up charge
every time that happens
what happens
locally is the
in the in the factory stream as i'm told
is these bags get
caught in the in the crunching phase if
that's the right term and they jam up
the machines so i am
sympathetic to that whole issue of mixed
streaming and and
making the communities pay more
because of the mixed stream that's not
well
supervised
on the other hand i i still haven't
reconciled in my mind how two
communities side by side
relatively the same size let me use
londonderry and hudson they're about the
same size communities
if one town has
a restriction as voted in the
restriction for plastic bags and
paper bags but the other town said no we
don't want to do that
what does that mean for the business
of
that those two towns are competing for
what will we be driving
customers to hudson if if londoner takes
the the option or
the other way
and that that's a concern that i have
when we when we leave it to be enabled
like this
is
we may see businesses
be being caught
at a disadvantage because their
community is going to choose how to
disposition these bags whether it be
plastic or whether they be paper
yes representative davis so there is
nothing in the statute that dictates
what businesses might need to do or not
do
if if a business in a neighboring
community just to
go with your example
decides not to
ban these single-use bags and the
neighbor next door does
doesn't say anything about what the
businesses in that community have to do
they can go along they can decide not to
use single plastic
bags anyway it's a private business the
state doesn't tell them what to do
true
yes representative power thank you mr
chair to be clear this this bill be well
can i speak to the bill or the amendment
uh
have we made a motion on the amendment
yes we have so just please talk to the
amendment at this point
so speaking to the amendment that would
limit my comments to the
i guess
phrase at point of sale is that correct
yes okay so i will defer once again
okay i think uh yes representative
i just um i could i could understand the
chairman's point about the uh the stream
issue i can i can see that
but my question is the practicality of
how this could be implemented
because
if you have two convenience stores
conv
to me grocery stores are not an issue
people people bring their own bags to
grocery stores and so
paper and plastic is no longer a big
deal
to me
but
convenience store when you just bop in
and get two or three items
and if they say do you want a bag okay
they don't give you an option
of paper or plastic they say do you want
a bag okay and in most cases the bag
that they offer you is a plastic bag
they don't offer you paper and plastic
so a convenience store
to me it would would really be hit on
this because they have to offer
generally speaking when people go into a
convenience store they're not going to
bring their own bag you know you're
going to just go in and pick something
up
and and if there are too many items to
carry out you're going to need to put it
in a bag so what kind of bag are you
going to put it in well
from a practicality standpoint
convenience stores are going to want to
offer plastic bags because they take up
less room and they're cheaper and
everything
so
i'm not sure how
if a town a municipality
said no more plastic bags
were done with plastic bags so how could
that be implemented in a convenience
representative
to address representative lasalle's
point
i i think that language in the amendment
that talks about regulating the
distribution i think that general enough
that a town may make a decision
that if if they are
going to let's say
require
grocery stores to
um ask if if a customer wants a bag in
the first place or if they're going to
say no plastic bags at all they could
exempt convenience stores there's
nothing in this that says that it's
going to be a blanket regulation i think
it gives them
the opportunity
to decide okay we're going to regulate
the distribution
but it doesn't say for everybody it
could just be for stores of certain size
very similar to what's already in
statute if you look at
one
n
regulating noise
in merrimack anyway
we don't ban noise we do regulate it for
certain hours
and you know so some businesses it might
create a lot of noise at night they're
they're out of luck but
um
you know
towns have a lot of different noise
ordinances so i would expect that
you know adding item q about the bags
there could be a lot of different
thank you
at this point
i think i'm going to move the question
we've had plenty of discussion
and
if my memory serves right which it might
not we're at the point where we have
right
and uh that that the motion is off the
path amendment after we had to uh adopt
okay uh so the motion is to adopt the
amendment as
presented um mr clerk would you take a
okay uh vice chairman pmrt
no
clerk for its no representative trip no
representative guthrie
representative los alas
no
uh representative rhodes
representative melvin no
representative here
rep is represented majority damn yes
representative tray 11 yes
representative gilman yes
representative stavis yes representative
megapudi
yes
representative vann
representative clee yes representative
gallagher
yes
mr chairman yes i'd like to make a
motion
yes please do it to itl 1119.
seeing none representing status could
you can ask the clerk to take a roll
bill 1119
representative pia monty
yes
correct votes yes representative tripp
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative rhodes yes
representative melvin yes
representative
representative power yes
representative majori
no representative
no
representative gilman no
representative davis no
representative megapootie no
representative van
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
representative no
chairman dolan
uh yes no i'm sorry
okay so uh with that motion failing
we have one more bill to take up and
that's
1081 which is
the discussion of the dissolution of a
the itl pass
okay so the the
the next and last bill for today as i'm
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take a recess and we'll pick up that
bill tomorrow
uh that's uh
okay so 1081 we'll take up first thing
tomorrow
plus
you